so there's only a number of ways maybe
he's trying to grip for me
and you're gonna pass just get the cross
grip
okay secure it at the elbow so it stays
diagonal move outside of it
come up to the head control
so just ideally one two three
my work
again he's going this way and i want to
go through
him
i'm going to just keep moving when my
knee hits the ground i got to be
able to stand up very quickly okay so
so on this side
it's right here right here so you just
take it
pollution
okay so one
i'm gonna use this is what i mean by
tightening up so you can see here is
here's the condition
but i don't want to lose him so i do all
this with my body on him
around her
that's what i mean keep chest the chest
okay